[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: The first
modern steam engine
was invented in England
in the early 1700s,
helping launch the
Industrial Revolution.
Today, there's a
return to steam power.
Due to its different
configuration and combustion
process, a steam engine
produces less pollution
than a regular internal
combustion engine.
This steam engine burns fuel in
an external combustion chamber.
The resulting heat turns water
into pressurized steam that
enters the cylinders,
pushing pistons,
turning a crank shaft that
powers the drive train.
Because this engine doesn't
burn fuel inside the cylinders
like a traditional
car engine, it
can run on any type or mixture
of fuels with fewer emissions.
The circular engine block
is made of aluminum.
Technicians install
studs to hold
six stainless steel cylinders.
Due to the constant
exposure to steam,
all engine parts are made
of rust proof materials.
The technicians insert a
piston into each cylinder.
The piston is
aluminum with a heat
resistant carbocation
and glider to isolate
it from the cylinder wall.
They connect the piston
rods to the crankshaft
in the center with the
specially designed component
called a spider bearing.
This bearing is designed to
modify the piston stroke,
producing a smoother rotation
of the crankshaft and more power
to the engine.
Unlike a traditional car
engine with cylinders arranged
in line, these cylinders are
in a radio configuration,
and therefore equidistant
from the center.
This prevents the
engine from warping
under high temperatures.
They place a counterbalance
over their spider
bearing to further smooth
the motion of the crankshaft.
Now, they install a
pushrod over each cylinder.
It operates a valve, which
let steam enter the cylinder
and move the piston.
They insert the base of each
pushrod into a guide ring.
Then attach the cylinder
heads, each of which
houses a steam entry valve.
They insert the
pushrod into the valve.
Then to complete
the engine assembly,
they install the cam,
which pushes the push
rods as the shaft spins.
The factory hooks
up every completed
engine for a couple of rounds
of performance testing.
First to trial run using air
pressure to check for leaks
and to verify that all
components operate correctly.
If everything's fine, then
they repeat the process
with steam pressure.
This type of steam engine can
power many types of machines
from cars, trucks, and
boats to electric generators
as we see here.
In a vehicle, it doesn't
require a transmission
because it produces so
much rotational power.
Now, for the heat exchanger.
The component which turns water
into engine powering steam.
Technicians use
a motorized wheel
to wind 20 feet of stainless
steel tubing into a coil.
They bind the coil
with steel thread,
putting a stitch in between each
tube to create a minute gap.
That way, when fuel burns
in the combustion chamber,
the heat can travel over
at in between the tubes,
heating the water inside faster
and more efficiently than
if the heat would contact
only the coils top
and bottom surfaces.
The result, superheated
steam in just 5 seconds.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
They stack six of
these coils, one
to feed steam to each cylinder.
This nest of tubes
form the engine's
primary heat exchanger.
They test it using any number
of fuels even waste fuels, which
would otherwise be
discarded, such as used motor
oil and used vegetable oil
from restaurant fryers.
Virtually anything that
burns will do the job.
The fuel combusts at low
pressure, not at high pressure
as in a gas or diesel engine.
That means burning fossil
fuels to make steam produces
far fewer greenhouse
gases and most
hydrocarbons burn off
completely within the sealed
combustion chamber.
You never have to refill
or top off the water,
because a condenser cools
the steam back into water,
which then circulates.
Water is not only
the working fluid,
it also acts as the
engine lubricant,
so the steam engine
doesn't require motor oil.
Besides fuel combustion,
this modern steam engine
can run off other heat
sources, such as solar heat
and exhaust heat from
furnaces or engines.
[MUSIC PLAYING]